one thing that's really interesting is
like you know you you watch Skin Tama
and you know you saw like oh you know
this is something that I finally want to
do and then the fact that you went and
[__] achieved that is like insane you
know that's like that's so [__]
awesome and like you know I guess like
now that you are kind of you know in
this like dream position that you put
yourself in now like do you now have
like a brand new goal that you want to
achieve in terms of like like you know
I'm sure as any games I'm a fan would
relate uh you know meeting Suite one day
would be that's a dream of mine I met
him oh you met him oh let's go
he gave me a birthday presentation
I brought it today
I don't know where my man it was in my
little makeup bag it's like my good luck
charm now such a wholesome yeah hell
yeah we got the good ending guys I mean
how was meeting so use the normal closet
like it was amazing well um first of all
you know when people go into the
entertainment industry they expect so
much like they expect glamor so oh thank
you so much I'm sorry there you go I'm
sorry
it's like a little keychain oh cute yeah
so I use it as like a good luck charm
but yeah
I think it's like a necktie but yeah
yeah you gave it to me this year for my
birthday so whenever I go into auditions
like I have this but it makes so much
sound the last time I was in the studio
please stop making noise yeah no I was
in the studio doing a tape recording and
my manager was like that's making too
much noise like you need to take that
off because I was having it right here
like no you don't understand what this
is voice acting a button shirt and they
were like can you not do that why like
it makes too much noise yeah
[Music]
how was the process of kind of you like
you mentioned that you said your
Japanese wasn't as good how was it kind
of almost relearning all of that and
getting it to a point where you had to
be like kind of native oh well I fully
memorize like two episodes of ginkama
like every single word yeah for the
first two episodes like I wrote it down
and that's impressive considering how
dialogue heavy Gintama is especially you
should re-watch the same movie over and
over again actually I did that yeah it
was actually a really good textbook
because there's so many like
um ways of speaking you know like
so and like the characters are really
distinct so it's like okay so people who
act like this like they say what does
she and people who act like this they
say like it's really like it really
helped me a lot and I would also
um watch the news programs and because
you know their intonation and their
pronunciation is like perfect yeah yeah
so
um I would basically just listen and
like say what they were saying yeah yeah
I mean I think like input is like one of
the most important things when it comes
to Japanese learning
um yeah when like how I got my listening
skills up was like very similar I it
turned out to be like dress up darling
uh I I chose for some reason uh just
because I wonder why okay wait wait hold
on let me let me continue
uh just because like I thought in terms
like the genre of anime I think like
high school romance is kind of like at a
level where it's like much more
comprehensible for someone just starting
to like get to learn Japanese because I
look at five lists I try listening to
[__] isekai I'll light novel
adaptations impossible I I I cannot even
comprehend half the stuff yeah because
like half the essay guys just like make
up words Japanese people won't even yeah
Japanese people like so why is it
written in kanju but it's like a German
word like how does that make any sense
yeah so I was like huh uh I think like
going for like a high school kind of
romance is the best way to go about it
for something that's like beginner level
for me yeah and dress up darling just
happened to be airing at that time and I
just like chose an episode and I watched
to re-watch it like about 20 times damn
um I know like like honestly that really
really helps at least my listening
skills how did you get your listening
skills up
I don't think it's dress-up dog
I don't know really I just I guess just
existing around here
I've been forced to like hear it all the
time and yeah yeah and the way I view it
is like it's like building a like a
bridge made of Legos but you can only
put like one block down at your feet
each time right you can only pick up and
build the connections and use muscle
memory yeah I've still got a long way to
go and also I think when you learn a
language in the way that I think we
probably learned it I feel like you do a
lot of lazy things where like sometimes
I won't listen to the full sentence I'm
waiting for you to say keywords so I can
like like this this with this context I
understand what you're saying yeah yeah
yeah which is like a bad habit which I
need to get out of because sometimes
I'll just listen to the sentence you'll
be like oh he said uh it's hot but he
said like five he said like a bunch of
different things around it which I
didn't really pay much attention I mean
I feel sometimes I do that that's what I
do it too yeah I think that's just like
a natural progression you go through
where it's like I can't be like you know
maybe like it helps you understand the
surrounding words more but it's yeah
it's all a slow process I think
consciously you're trying to listen to
every single word that makes up the
sentence but subconsciously you're like
oh he said hot and today so he must be
just talking about the weather you know
it just feel like you're like I'm like a
game show where you're listening to a
question and you're just waiting for
like some key part of the question to be
answered so yeah yeah I got it it's kind
of like yeah yeah did you did you have
to learn kanji at all yes like I mean I
still can't read that much kanji which
was a problem for me actually this year
when I was hosting the Crunchyroll anime
Awards I saw that oh yeah yeah
what is your favorite people's name
people's names but also um the script
was really long but I got the script
like a day or like two days before but
um usually for like aof 2020 like for
this year like every year we would have
the script right in front of us right so
um I could write like how to read yeah
but for countryable they wanted to make
it like an American award show so you
couldn't have the script in front of you
like there was a prompter in front of
you so I couldn't write like what the
kanji like meant or like how to read it
but I literally got the script last
night so I'm like I don't know how to
read that
and also I'm like my eyesight is really
bad so like usually the words would be
like this small but I had to like have
them
that's really bad for a telephone
yeah and it wasn't like the sentences
were like all broken into like lines
because I had to make it that big it
doesn't matter it's like and the award
goes to
uh yeah
there was a moment where it was like
or something like that where it was like
you know it was like really popular all
over the world yeah but I just
remembered that you know like the kin
part while reading the script but like
during the actual work show I didn't
know how to read it so I said
which is like yeah it got discovered
you're not wrong
yeah but yeah so people who already knew
the script was like oh my gosh there's
all the stuff yeah I saw there was a
moment on the award show where like your
contact lens or something fell out as
well just just add like insult on like
yeah like everything you had to like
juggle at the same time I couldn't sleep
for like two weeks after that
because during the stream you guys can't
hear it but people the second my
contacts fell out and I looked like
behind me to fix it yeah yeah you can
hear the crowd being like
oh [__] and that voice haunted me that's
what I hear in my mind yeah yes it
haunted me and you know I was like I'm
probably never gonna be invited back so
like whatever I'm just you know I'm just
gonna like Wing It excuse me you handed
it like a professional one yeah the way
you handled it just I I was just like
nah I'm all right this is this is a
professional I should be taking notes I
don't think there's many other people
they can ask
a handful of people they could ask I
went I went um backstage after that and
I was crying into my management like I
can't but they were like you need to go
back in five minutes
as as long as people watch and uh that's
all that really matters it is always
interesting whenever we have to um live
promotion stuff with um working on more
of the Japanese side because they always
want a script yeah and we're like no no
we are we don't do that either yeah and
I'll be like you tell me what to say and
I'll put it in naturally they're like
what if you say something bad I'm like I
would say something bad I know what I'm
doing it's like I don't have to rest
yeah yeah there's always just kind of
that worry that like we just want to
know exactly what you're going to say
yeah oh it's live you know yeah but it's
also that you know ironic thing of like
you know they prepare like these like
insanely long scripts and then I've been
in situations where it's like you know a
five to ten page script for something
right and it's like uh yeah so we just
finished and we only actually read like
three of these Pages
sometimes you you'll give them sometimes
the rest for a script do they want to
rough it you'll say and you've sent it
to them and then on the day just when
you're reading it like oh this isn't the
vibe I'm just gonna change it yeah live
yeah yeah normally everyone's always
happy because it's like you know I think
you is the MC you normally do a good
read of what it's all doing and you can
be like I think this is a better idea
yeah like uh out of all like the live
shows and like events I've done with
Japanese companies what the vibe I get
is that they want everything to go on
script word for words before the event
happens yeah and then the event happens
and you turn up and you're like uh so is
it okay if I just get the gist of it and
everyone's like yeah yeah sure because
there's no way you can memorize I feel
bad for these script right
it just does to memorize like 10 like
you've mentioned like 10 pages yeah
if you gave me five years yeah I could
barely memorize my own birthday yeah
this is not gonna happen yeah I'll
figure it out but for me though because
I'm so bad at public speaking that kind
of helps me yeah
they don't know they don't want to
assume that you're comfortable always
being able to just be like yeah I'll do
it yeah I suppose it's your voice acting
experience has played into that as well
because I mean that's where you
definitely have a script that you have
to read off of that can't be changed